man muss einfach sehen was wir hier in
den grundschulen was das für die kinder
bedeutet dass wir drehen jetzt über
schließungen von acht wochen
wir hatten im frühjahr haben wir gerade
für die kleinsten hatten wir
schließungen von drei bis vier monaten
das addiert sich ja alles in der
bildungsbiografie alles indes und ein
kunst- und kind lernt mich wollen
rechner lesen und schreiben das heißt
das kann bei vielen kindern an schaden
der bildungsbiographie anrichten wenn
sie in sie lebenslang nicht mehr
loswerden und dieses dieses
unglaublichen schadens muss man sich
bewusst sein
hinzu kommt ja auch dass kinder
wirklicher sie ihr lebensinhalt weit
gehen fällt ihre schule ist ja so viel
mehr als nur bildung
dazu gibt es auch die vereine sind dicht
es gibt keinen sportlichen angebote mehr
viele kinder sie ihre großeltern nicht
mehr
kaum noch freunde für vierjährige das
muss man sich klarmachen
ihre fünfjährige die können sich in die
zeit bookrunner überhaupt nicht mehr
erinnern
deswegen genauso sie sprechen sehr
emotional und eben auch mit den
erfahrungen die sie haben über das thema
bilder an der ehemalige
regierungssprecher
wir haben ein ganz besonderes zitat von
angela merkel heute erlebt eine emotion
ich lese es noch einmal vor ich lasse
mir nicht anhängen dass ich kinder
quälen hat sie in richtung von manuela
schwesig der mecklenburg-vorpommerschen
ministerpräsidentin gesagt villa du
kennst dich aus dem politischen berlin
wie gesagt du was regierungssprecher was
glaubst du warum hat die kanzlerin das
gesagt naja angela merkel weiß dass ein
solches zitat natürlich die
öffentlichkeit kommen kann und ich gehe
fest davon aus dass sie hier
solchen versuchen von manuela schwesig
sie diese ecke zu treiben widersprechen
volt und ganz deutlich machen sollte ich
bin nicht diejenige die hier dafür
verantwortlich ist dass kinder
möglicherweise diese folgen haben
die frau schröder hier gerade
beschrieben hat insofern wollte sie da
einen stopper setzen ganz klar machen
auch
ich bin hier nicht verantwortlich für
das was wir auf korinther pandemie
machen tun müssen auch um diesen pohlers
des corona virus möglicherweise der
mutierten der zeo zu stoppen sondern ich
bin daran interessiert diese mutation zu
stoppen natürlich kann man nicht angela
merkel unterstellen dass sie unsere
kinder quälen will oder dass sie uns
alle dauerhaft in diesen lockdown
bringen will
man hätte dieses zitat allerdings etwas
erweitern können und sagen können ich
will nicht dafür verantwortlich gemacht
werden nicht nur kinder zu quälen
sondern auch ihre eltern sind auch das
sollte man sehr deutlich machen
diese zeit ist auch für jede wäre jedes
elternpaar unglaublich anstrengend die
schulpflichtige geben egal wie alt um
diese dadurch zu bringen frau schröder
sie haben gerade schon auch sehr
emotional darüber gesprochen was das für
kinder bedeutet jetzt haben wir gerade
das zitat von angela merkel noch einmal
gesehen sie will sich das nicht anhängen
lassen die kinder zu quälen was denken
sie was sind das für qualen die die
kinder jetzt in dieser zeit miterleben
und ist das auch jetzt die richtige
messe die angela merkel jetzt mit diesem
zitat bei dem sie wusste dass es auf
jeden fall der öffentlichkeit besprochen
wird gesendet hat also was ja zumindest
mal heißt ist bis heute existenziell um
das thema schulen und kitas gerungen
wurde
und ich finde das ist schon mal ein
wohltuender unterschied zum zum frühjahr
und frühsommer als wir ja miterleben
mussten wie wie so vieles bereiche
geöffnet wurden wie wir erwachsenen
schon wieder shoppen gegangen sind und
falls doch mal auf den fitness studio
und die schulen gerade die grundschulen
immer noch nicht waren
da schneit es mir eine einer echten band
gegeben zu haben bei allen beteiligten
beim bundeskanzleramt bei den 16
ministerpräsidenten ist für sie jetzt
das thema schule und was das für kinder
und familien bedeutet eine wesentlich
höhere priorität
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren